the Oscars are predictably irritating
Joe Biden stumbles even as he correctly
diagnoses his own party and the other
Democrats open up the circular firing
squad
I'm pencha Pierrot this is the ben
shapiro show today's show is sponsored
by express @ VPN at my Southie thin
secure their internet join them and
express it VPN comm / band well you may
have noticed that things are crazy right
it's just the beginning of the year
we've already seen mass chaos cats and
dogs living together
chaos industries like the whole thing
well this is why you might want to think
about diversify your portfolio at least
a little bit and one of the ways you can
diversify your portfolio is to put at
least a little bit of your money in
precious metals I'm not saying take all
of your money out of the stock market
like WA date it put it in gold bars and
bury them in your backyard I'm talking
about have a little bit of your money in
precious metals because the fact is the
government messes around with the
currency the government messes around
with the value of things that you own so
why wouldn't you at least diversify and
is something that the government doesn't
really control and that is the price of
gold if you haven't yet taken the first
step of requesting a free information
kit on gold go ahead and do it if you
haven't converted a portion of your
eligible IRA or 401k to an IRA and
precious metals at least go and have the
conversation purged gold will go to work
and make things super simple there's no
obligation to have nothing to lose to
take that first step
Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau so text Ben - 47 47 47
during the month of February when you
open an IRA and precious metals you do
get a signed copy of my book the right
side of history for free the deal was
extended from January don't know how
long it's gonna last so you have to text
Ben - 47 47 47 in February in open an
IRA and precious metals and get a signed
copy of my book the right side of
history
the real reason of course that you
should go and check out Birch gold is
because you should have all the
information now to get a free copy of my
book instead go check them out ask all
of your questions then once you have
your answers talk with the folks with at
Birch gold about throwing business texts
Ben 247 at 47 47 that's been - 47 47 47
ok so last night was the Oscars ooh and
the Oscars are a wonderful window into
what the cultural left really thinks of
America
the Oscars every year do more to help
President Trump than any other cultural
event in America truly because it's
finally when the American people get to
see what all of the people on the coast
truly think of them and as I say
I don't think that everybody on the
coasts really thinks the with the people
at the Oscars think but enough of them
do and it is amusing I will say to watch
the Oscars out woke themselves basically
the Oscars writ large are this story
that I talked about on the show last
week this is sure I talked about on the
show last week where a bunch of liberal
white women we're hiring a couple of
women of color to lecture them about how
unwell they were they were paying them
like 2500 bucks a session in order to
have malice struggle sessions where they
confessed how secretly racists they were
and how they were insensitive and
couldn't identify microaggressions and
all of this and the real reason to do
that is so then you could then you can
go tell all of your left-leaning friends
that you are the kind of person who is
so woke that you paid twenty five
hundred bucks to a lady to explain to
you how you are not how you are not woke
enough I mean this is this is the idea
here it's really because the impressive
level of subversive racism that exists
in the left-wing community it truly is
incredible it truly is incredible okay
so the the the upper-class posh white
kind of looking down your nose at black
people in that black people are only
there to alleviate your sense of guilt
in the way that you alleviate your sense
of guilt is by hiring black people to
tell you that you're actually guilty
it's really really impressive and that's
what was happening at the Oscars last
night there's a lot of racial signaling
it was also a lot of class signaling
nothing more woke than a bunch of
incredibly incredibly rich people who go
out there and use their richness to push
for socialism nothing says that you are
woke quite late not giving up any of
your money like still taking millions
and millions of dollars to do these
movies but then complaining about class
conflict and this is one way at least to
see the win for parasite which again
I've only watched about half of parasite
at this point and seems like a fine
movie I really but it is a class
conflict parable and folks in Hollywood
love this kind of stuff you have to
understand that the Oscars really
operate more like the viewer function on
Rotten Tomatoes some Rotten Tomatoes
when they rate movies there are two
ratings there's the critics ratings and
then there's the the audience rating and
the audience rating is usually how does
this film fulfill expectations how does
this film make me feel about me the same
thing is true to a certain extent the
critics how does this film make me feel
about me which is why my rule on Rotten
Tomatoes if it's above 90% there's a
really good chance that the movie is
terrible and if it's below 60% there's a
really good chance that the
he's terrible okay well in Hollywood the
question for the Oscars is always how
does this film make me feel about me and
that's why you see films like Birdman
which no one saw and of the people who
saw it few liked its how that movie ends
up winning Best Picture because people
in Hollywood are obsessed with
themselves
it's how the movie moonlight wins an
Oscar not because it was the best movie
that year it wasn't but because it made
people in Hollywood feel really good
about themselves to reward a movie that
was about a black gay kid right this is
how Hollywood views itself so for
parasite the question is why would
parasite win and sure it's a fine movie
but they're a bunch of really good
movies made last year including 1917
which is going to go down in five years
is one of the better film war films ever
made
Ford versus Ferrari which is gonna be a
basic-cable classic Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood were just Tarantino's best
film in 10 years people are not gonna
remember a parasite in ten years people
are gonna remember a lot of the other
films that were made this year the
reason that Hollywood rewarded this is
for two reasons one they get to now
claim that they are woke because they're
awarded a class conflict script and two
because they now get to claim they're
woke because they're awarded a foreign
film and this was the only way of
avoiding the innate conflict of having
mainly white films nominated this is all
we heard about in the run-up to the
Oscars is how white the Oscars were
hashtag Oscars so white so white and so
give it to a South Korean film and then
you don't have to worry about being
accused of racism anymore now
hilariously enough those same white
people who voted for parasite will be
very much in favor of South Koreans
being barred from Harvard so long as it
means that affirmative action can apply
to people of other races see if you're
South Korea and you're only a member of
minority group for certain purposes but
not other purposes but in any case this
may be to deeper read let's go into what
exactly happen at the Oscars last night
so as I say this Oscars as most Oscars
have turned into was the equivalent of a
bunch of liberal white ladies hiring a
couple of women of color in order to
inform them how racist they are so they
hired Janelle Monae who has you know
she's talented lady but she's basically
made a living the past few years kind of
social justice warrior in a little bit
and and she starts off the Oscars by
lecturing Americans about how the
Academy is anti anti queer and anti
black because she is queer in black and
that's why she's special as opposed to
she's talented so she's special she's
talented because she's clear and black
which is weird because neither of those
are talents in any case here is
gentleman a
[Applause]
we don't get alone we don't take it to
the underground this is so toned up it's
so insanely toned up first of all I
don't know what happened if she was
attacked by a florist shop but you but
she's walking around wearing a big old
cape that's made of flowers and talking
about let's talk about all the women who
made great films this year and the idea
is that everybody is horrible for not
nominating these women for Best Director
okay the the films that were supposed to
be nominated for Best Film this year or
Best Director for these women almost
universally were not incredibly good
films you know I haven't seen Little
Women which apparently should have
picked up every Oscar that was ever made
like including alt retro actively every
Oscar that has been made since the
beginning of time because it's made by
Greta Gerwig and we know Greta Gerwig
has put upon because she was nominated
for Lady Bird two years ago but in any
case chinami nathan starts going down
the front row to all of these rich white
people and trying to hijack them into
proclaiming they're woken us with her
right you can see Tom Hanks trying to
Bob his head to the beat a little bit
and it's like me framed by my head to
the beat right at me I'm a white guy
like not not really not a thing that is
happening in the video of this is so
spectacular
Janome a just walking around so it's
like an entirely white front row in
entirely white front row right and she's
walking around with the microphone
trying to cuddle them into being part of
a really really awkward looking legged
Tom Hanks being like okay am I supposed
to Bob my head here what am I what's
going on now how did I find myself at
this at this off-broadway creative
theatre production like what exactly is
happening here and that was just the
beginning guys by the way if you ever
want to see awkward white people if you
ever want to see awkward white people I
will say that the Oscars are a great
place to see awkward white people Eminem
who is another white person mm
apparently rapped at the Oscars last
night the cutaways to the audience are
just gold they're just gold because
nobody in the audience knows what the
hell is going on Eminem is up on stage
yelling and rapping and cursing and
everybody in the audience is super
confused and it's just fantastic
you know let's show some of the video of
this this is really spectacular
they all look puzzled they don't know
what's going on oh the awkwardness oh
it's so awkward
all of these the best part of that
Scorsese is looking about like a Marvel
Avengers film he's just like I don't
know what no oh great stuff okay so
Hollywood wasn't done there then you got
the speeches and the speeches were all
about how woke they were they were all
about how woke and crazily woke they
were okay so Josh GAD right gets up and
he and he explains that he is a special
person why because he's not a climate
denier he somehow sneaks this into a
joke about frozen - again oh this is
gonna make from president again now you
have to understand then for most people
who see any clip from this show what
they're going to feel is an overwhelming
sense of irritation at these annoying
extraordinarily wealthy jackasses who
poses our moral superior's while doing
nothing actually morally superior and
the ways that they poses our moral
superiors are by either paying homage to
the woke culture like by bobbing their
heads to you know mandate doing her
routine or by getting up there and
claiming that everyone else is an idiot
so Josh GAD does this routine about
climate change again one of the great
irritants about the climate change talk
is nobody ever talks about solutions
when it comes to climate change it all
becomes virtue signaling about how
wonderful they are for believing in
climate change in the first place so
Josh GAD did that routine trying to of
course to ride half the country in the
in the middle of this as min denoted
animated movies are loved everywhere in
fact frozen - or as climate change
deniers call it not frozen - has been
dubbed in 45 different languages which
means I now have 44 blood rivals around
the world these dubbed versions provide
kids and adults everywhere their own
special connection to the story and it's
characters which means there are so many
great versions of Elsa for instance
Canadian Elsa is basically the same but
with healthcare just the Oscars
you guys are so in touch it's really
it's really great see how in such an
hour we'll get to more of the Oscars in
a second and again this is important
because the culture wars are an inherent
part of our culture more and more so
I'll explain why in just a few minutes
but first let's talk about
the window coverings in your home so the
window coverings in your home you may
not think about them very much but the
fact is you should think about them
because they are one of the easy
upgrades that you can make to your house
and you can do it and make your house
look much better and not spend a fortune
doing it how should you do this well
should head on over to blinds comm with
15 million windows covered over thirty
thousand five star customer reviews
blinds.com is America's number one
online retailer for affordable quality
custom window coverings whether you're
looking for energy-efficient energy
efficiency you just moved or you want to
refresh the look of your home blinds.com
makes the whole experience fast and easy
plus every order gets free samples free
shipping a free online design
consultation to make sure that
everything looks as good in person as it
does online just send them pictures of
your house and they send back a custom
recommendations from a professional for
what will work with your color scheme
furniture and specific rooms and this is
the best part if you accidentally
mismeasure or if you pick the wrong
color if you screw up blindness comm
will remake your blinds for free they've
really made it easy for you so there's
no excuse to leave up those mangled
blinds for a limited time a my listeners
get 20 bucks off at blinds comm when you
use promo code Ben that is blinds.com
promo code Ben for $20 off faux wood
blinds cellular shades roller shades and
more we've done this in our house it
makes our house look a lot better blinds
calm promo code Ben rules and
restrictions to apply that is blinds.com
promo code Ben go check them out right
now blinds.com promo code Ben for $20
off ok Brad Pitt also got up at the
Oscars and decided that he was going to
jump into the political act I definitely
trust the judgment of somebody who was
in relationships with both Jennifer
Aniston and Angelina Jolie because
that's definitely showing some good life
judgment there anyway here is Brad Pitt
explaining his perspective on the
impeachment hearings which is something
you definitely needed to hear based on
the fact that he was once in seven years
in Tibet and therefore knows all about
politics or something here's Brad Pitt
saying things Thank You the Academy for
this honor of honors they told me I only
have 45 seconds up here which is 45
seconds more than the Senate gave John
Bolton this week I'm thinking maybe
Quentin doesn't move you about it in the
end the adults do the right thing and
they're all laughing don't you see
because that they're laughing oh it's
just great okay the virtue signaling was
not limited to inside
the whole Natalie Portman decided she
was gonna virtues signal also again the
lack of any sense of reality among these
people is insane they're so you know
these people they are so brave so are
the stunning miss the bravery how could
they be so brave and yet so
controversial at the same time such
stunning brave early bravery Natalie
Portman who is wealthy beyond wealthy a
Natalie Portman who's been given at
least one out and I she wasn't asking
for Black Swan so she she herself has
been heavily rewarded despite in my
opinion being a wildly overrated actress
in any case she shows up on the red
carpet wearing a cape but it's not just
any cape it's a cape that is embroidered
with female directors the names of
female directors who are not nominated
and therefore are greatly put upon
despite the fact that they are in
millions of dollars to direct apparently
mediocre films I mean seriously the
names of the directors that are on there
on her cape they include the director of
hustlers really does anyone think that
hustlers deserve the best director Nam
this year like does anyone think that
hustlers really really required a Best
Director nomination this year one of the
directors is the director of the mr.
Rogers films anyone think that the mr.
Rogers film deserves a Best Director
nomination this year does anyone think
that Greta Gerwig desperately needed a
Best Director nomination after winning a
Best Director nomination for Lady Bird
and what exactly are we talking about
here the bottom line is that according
to Hollywood
this makes Natalie Portman not have to
worry about the fact that she was
wealthy and that she has a really easy
life she is now part of the victimized
right she's part of the coalition of the
dispossessed and so the question becomes
dispossessed by whom so people do this
routine or well dispossessed by the
Academy because the Academy is the font
of all evil it's super white so what is
the Academy do instead of the Academy
making fun of all this nonsense the
Academy jumps right into it and they
flagellate themselves and the Academy
brings all these people forward and then
they said look how look we know that
we've got a problem guys we know that
we've got a problem and the first step
towards solving a problem is admitting
you have a problem and bringing forth
people like Natalie Portman a true
victim in American society when I think
that Tim I think Natalie Portman's don't
usual is in France with her husband I
feel really really terrible for Natalie
Portman it's it's and I feel terrible
for all those directors we're given
millions and millions of dollars to play
with to make really really kind of
mediocre films that's that's pretty
tacular so at least I will hand it to
Joaquin Phoenix at least Joaquin Phoenix
is crazy
all these other people are pretty much
saying so when they do stupid things
then you just make fun of them Joaquin
Phoenix I'm not sure whether you're even
allowed to make fun of Joaquin Phoenix
at this point because honestly I like
he's sort of morphed into is he still
role-playing is he's still just being
the Joker did he ever get out of the
mindset so Joaquin Phoenix gets up there
and he's been going around making these
sort of environmentalist statements he
really made a sacrifice for the people
this year and for the people of Earth he
only has one tuxedo walk in Phoenix he
pointed this out that unlike all these
other people with 10 tuxedos he only has
one tuxedo I just like all the poor
people only have one tuxedo if you go
below the poverty line everybody's going
to tuck a tux
$1,000 tux hanging in their closet in
any case Joaquin Phoenix wins Best Actor
for the Joker and he makes an insane
speech about cows and milk which is
weird because I recently saw Joaquin
Phoenix wearing a vegan t-shirt at a
restaurant that serves pretty much only
meat in any case here's my true story
here is Joaquin Phoenix last night at
the Oscar lecturing us all about
speciesism speciesism which is again a
real hot take that really is the tragedy
I mean truly Joaquin Phoenix should have
shown up with the names of cows
embroidered on his tuxedo human-like
Betsy old blue right I mean they weren't
nominated for anything either
these cows that have given us our
sustenance for generations and not one
of them was nominated for an award not a
single one of them was nominated for an
award not a single cow unbelievable
here's Joaquin Phoenix explaining to all
of us that veganism is the way to go and
that basically drinking milk is like
you're not see we go into the natural
world and we plunder it for its
resources we feel entitled to
artificially inseminate a cow and when
she gives birth we steal her baby even
though her cries of anguish are
unmistakable and then we take her milk
that's intended for a calf and we put it
in our coffee and our cereal Oh what
what know what now like between we have
to embroider his coat with with with
milk
like 2% whole I mean what is wrong with
you people what is wrong with you people
no listen if you want to make the case
against factory farming make the case
against factory farming but we
artificially inseminate these cows and
then we take her milk and we use it in
our coffee we use it in our cereal yes
we do that's true
you you have you have scored a point
against civilization mr. Phoenix just
Wow
solid Sun and the crowd gave him a
standing ovation for this all of whom
drink milk by the way all of whom are
engaging in protein consumption animal
protein consumption like number of
vegans in that room not that high but
again it's all about the we've been
lectured and we know that we've been
lectured we this is the new church it
really is it's a church for folks on the
left just like a lot of people go to
church to be lectured by their pastor
about all the sins that they've
committed the prior weeks that they
don't commit those sins again it's like
that at the Oscars it's the one time
they go to church every year and at that
church they're lectured about their
insufficient wellness and if they wish
to avoid anti walk hell then they will
have to pay homage and they'll have to
do confession with Joaquin Phoenix which
is a really weird type of confession so
good stuff over at the Oscars as per the
usual really in touch with the feelings
of most Americans I think that these
people really have a bead on what
Americans are feeling and honestly I was
feeling a little optimistic this year
because there were some actual movies
that people saw this year and none of
them want any awards I mean the ones
that actually won awards once upon a
time in Hollywood got completely skunked
Joker won a couple of awards but
parasite waltzed away with bunch of
these awards a movie that no American
has really ever seen and again a class
warfare film that would have please
Bernie Sanders is if the rest of the
film holds up the way that it's holding
up so far on our n in any case we'll get
to we'll get to the actual 2020
Democratic race and I'll explain in just
a second why these cultural Wars
actually matter because whenever we
sound off about this kind of stuff
people on the Left they're like how dare
you say you're so triggered by the
culture you're so triggered which is
gaslighting because the reason you do
this is because you want attention right
you're all the the 15 year old girl who
gets her hair put up in some sort of
mohawk and gets a giant nose ring gets
those those earrings that like stretch
out your earlobe and then you're walking
like why are you looking at me why are
you looking at me why are you your the
Oscars that's why we're looking at you
we all get it yeah we all get the you
want attention so if we
give you attention you don't get to
whine about us giving you attention and
if we make fun of you you don't get to
whine about us making fun of you of
course we're making fun of you because
you look like idiots you look like a
bunch of woke morons who have no actual
relationship what like is there a single
impoverished person in America who feels
better off today because of what was
done at the Oscars last night whose
whose pocketbook got thicker last night
is there a single woman in America who's
struggling to make ends meet who is like
yes slay Queen because female directors
weren't winning Oscar nom this year slay
Queen Natalie Portman who out there felt
really emboldened and empowered by that
Oscar routine last night I've been
feeling not all that many people not all
that many people except for the Oscar
voters who feel really good about
themselves because again they get to
participate in this religious ceremony
once a year
yeah well gets you more of this in one
second first you must not forget
Valentine's Day Valentine's Day is
coming up it is coming up quickly and I
know what's gonna happen you're gonna
forget and then you're going to drive
over to the local gas station you're
gonna buy your spouse your significant
other a box of gas station sushi aren't
you don't do it instead go over to 1-800
flowers and make the magic happen for
that special someone valentine's Day is
just a few days away so if you still
have an ordered roses you need to act
fast with the official Valentine florist
1-800 flowers calm right now you can get
the 24 stem colorful roadmap rose medley
for only $29.99 that is right the 24
stem a colorful rose medley for only
$29.99 or upgrade to 24 red roses for
only $10 more roses from 1-800 flowers
are picked at their peak they're shipped
overnight to ensure freshness I have a
bouquet that I recently got my wife from
1-800 five every time I go out to town
actually I get my wife flowers from
1-800 flowers and just that kind of
husband and you can be too they are
beautiful they really last they'll
beuter that they're gorgeous the 24 stem
color for rose medley for only $29.99 or
an upgrade to 24 red roses for just 10
bucks more it's one of the best
Valentine's Day offers you will find it
expires today while supplies last so
like today is the last chance pick your
delivery date let 1-800 flowers handle
the rest
when it comes to impressing her on
Valentine's Day trust in the rose
authority 1-800 flowers calm to order
the 24/7 colorful Rose medley for $29.99
or upgrade to 24 red roses for only $10
more go to 1-800 flowers calm /
Shapiro's order today and save at 1-800
flowers calm / apparel hurry the offer
expires soon that's 1-800 flowers calm
Shapiro's hurry that offer does expire
soon these flowers are the most
beautiful flowers in the world okay so
what the left will do is whenever a
culture war is declared they say why is
the right suit triggered by this why are
you so upset by this where you were
watching you didn't have to watch that's
true I didn't have to watch and the
truth is I didn't watch part of it
because why would I but when you declare
war in the culture that stuff has deeper
roots it does it has these deeper roots
and that was not the only again it was a
theme throughout the night never has
anybody gotten up at the Oscars and just
given like a basic American tribute it's
been years but we actually have full-on
communist tribute last night the
producers of Best Documentary got up
there and actually cited Karl Marx on
the stage which is really rich because
again these people are all really rich
here are some of the some of the people
who made the best documentary feature
literally quoting Karl Marx working
people have it harder and harder these
days and we believe that things will get
better
when workers of the world unite workers
of the world unite
literally quoting Karl Marx from a stage
where everybody is worth a fortune most
Americans are not going to be up for
this ok but this does have this does
have some pretty significant cultural
ramifications and it's carried over into
the Democratic Party because the Oscars
are writ small what the Democratic Party
is writ large there are in American
industry at classically American
industry typically the face to the world
and they used to be fairly Pro America
and now they've become the repository of
all things woke and all of the sort of
normal people in Hollywood have been
cowed into silence right everybody in
Hollywood is now Tom Hanks with regard
to nominate just sitting there trying to
bop along with the beat not
understanding what the hell is going on
and that's what's happening in the
Democratic Party to where Bernie Sanders
has the mic where tonic EC Coates has
the mic where where the woke left of the
party has the mic and now they are
attempting to cuddle everyone else into
silence with the accusation that if you
do not go along with their
extraordinarily far left agenda then
therefore you're part of the problem now
you are an accessory to the crime after
the fact and this is the fight that's
going on inside the Democratic Party
it's part of the fight that's going on
inside the country at large right now is
that there is a small contingent of
people in the United States who believe
that the United States is responsible
for nearly every evil in American
society who and we're
society a contingent of people who
believe that Americans are sinners
brutal egregious sinners against the
environment against minorities against
poor people and that if you disagree
with that you better keep your mouth
shut
that was the Oscars and that's the
impression that I think a lot of
Americans are getting of the Oscars and
that's why they're like okay screw this
Trump hates the Oscars like if Ricky
Gervais swear on the ballot they vote
for Ricky Gervais who by the way had a
great tweet last night he was how
specifically what he would have said at
the Oscars if he were the Oscar opener
he said I'm glad that you all decided to
give three hours of sleep
to your underpaid foreign-made which is
exactly right exactly right all these
people will go home to their underpaid
nannies from foreign countries who
they're making movies about their
victimization and who they thrust their
kids off upon right they'll go back home
to those people and then they will treat
them like dirt because the the truth is
that the villain the kind of upper-class
villains in parasite are more like the
people in Hollywood then the then the
lower-class heroes a pair of parasite
okay
so meanwhile over in the 2020 democratic
race as I say the Oscars are sort of a
very microcosmic version of the 2020
Democratic race you can see all of the
socialism versus non socialism breaking
out into the open all the candidates are
now going after each other
brutally then the most humorous moment
over the weekend so the Democrats had
this final debate before New Hampshire
New Hampshire is stacking up like
another Bernie Sanders win although Pete
Budaj edge has made some significant
gains really at the expense of Joe Biden
according to the latest polling data
from at New Hampshire
Sanders remains up and he remains up
fairly significantly but the real story
is not where Sanders is where Biden is
Biden has dropped almost down into
single digits according to the latest
polling average the latest polling
average has Bernie Sanders at twenty
eight point five Peabody judge at 22
Elizabeth Warren at 12 Biden at 11 and
Klobuchar at 11 he has nearly dropped
into fifth place in New Hampshire
according to the polling average this is
somebody who's running 2nd or 1st in
many of the polls just six weeks ago so
Biden has completely collapsed
Budda judge has picked up some of that
support Sanders is writing exactly where
Sanders has been writing the whole time
then the conventional wisdom was that at
some point Bernie Sanders's support
would bleed away to some other candidate
who could cross over between the social
space and the non socialist base as it
turns out bernie is absolutely
rock-solid and its Biden's support that
is bled away two other candidates
include
Pete Buddha judge but what really has
happened here is that the Democratic
Party is Tom Hanks in that Oscars clip
the Democratic Party is sitting there
and they don't know what to do as they
are lectured on their own lack of woken
us so at the debate on Friday night all
the Democratic candidates were asked
about having a Democratic Socialist at
the top of the ticket this is clip 23
and they're asked do any of you raise
your hand if you think it's a problem
having a Democratic Socialist at the top
of the ticket and watch as all of these
candidates basically stand there and do
nothing
Amy Klobuchar gradually raises her hand
before she realizes she's not supposed
to raise her hand
is anyone else on the stage concerned
about having a Democratic Socialist at
the top of the Democratic ticket okay
and Amy Klobuchar hesitates and then she
gradually raises her hand now why isn't
every hand going up literally everyone
on the stage except for Bernie Sanders
has expressed that they are unhappy with
the idea of having a Democratic
Socialist at the top of the ticket the
reason they're not raising their hands
because they're all afraid Bernie's
gonna win the nomination and then that's
gonna be a campaign ad every single
Democrat raising their hand except for
Bernie talking about how socialism
should not be at the top of the ticket
they're all dishonest they're radically
dishonest hey Joe Biden who did not
raise his hand there he did not raise
his hand he was asked about socialism
and he's been going around at rallies
and saying listen we can't defend
socialism at the top of the ticket this
is not something that we can do Florida
wind with a label Democratic Socialist
because everybody's gonna go all the way
down the line that's just kind of
happened you can win in North Carolina
gonna win in Pennsylvania you're gonna
win in those states in the Midwest it's
not I'm not I didn't put the label on
Bernie Bernie calls himself a Democratic
Socialist
so you think flat out Democrats can't
defeat Trump if they have to defend
socialism I think it's gonna be
incredibly more difficult okay Bernie
Sanders for his part he's saying on the
one hand he's not really a socialist on
the other hand Americans love socialism
so Bernie Sanders over the weekend he
said he was not advocating a US
government takeover of the health care
system so he's gonna have to explain
what the hell Medicare for all is I mean
that is literally a government takeover
of the US health care system but here is
Bernie trying to explain why it's not
advocating for the empowerment of the US
government to take over the entire
health care system this just optically
no hold it already
it's own more Brutus Margaret that's not
a true statement I'm not advocating for
the United States government to take
over the healthcare system what I am
advocating for is an expansion of
Medicare Medicare exists I want to
explain right now but it but it's not a
takeover yes it is Medicare is a portion
of the US healthcare system it's not the
entire US healthcare system that's like
saying that if you wanted to nationalize
FedEx that wouldn't be a government
takeover of the mail system because the
US Postal Service already exists no it
would absolutely be a takeover of the US
mail system but what the hell are you
talking about Bernie isn't even coherent
but at least he's coherent when he calls
for socialism right Bernie says
Americans want socialism they're
desperate for socialism they don't even
know what they want
I won't pooping and I want socialism
I've got I've got two things to do
socialism and putting them all out of
putting Americans out or out of pudding
they would like pudding socialism for
all the truth is that our agender is
precisely the agenda to the overwhelming
majority the american people want at the
end of the day the american people want
to raise the minimum wage to 15 bucks an
hour they want to make public colleges
and universities tuition-free and cancel
student debt by a modest tax on Wall
Street speculation the American people
understand health care is a human right
not a privilege the function of health
care is not to make 100 billion dollars
for the drug companies and the insurance
companies the American people understand
we have got to deal with the existential
threat of climate change our agenda is
the agenda of working-class and
middle-class Americans again he's put
he's promoting out that right and he
said socialism since all that radical
over the weekend is well Bernie because
Social it's not it's not radical anymore
apparently it's mainstream four years
ago when I was here campaigning many of
the ideas that we talked about raising
the minimum wage to a living wage of 15
bucks an hour though
ideas then were considered radical you
know what they're not radical today
seven states have passed a $50 dollar
minimum wage he's I'm just gonna remind
you I'm just gonna remind you here every
Democrat except for a me club which are
kept their hands down when asked if it
was a problem to have a socialist at the
top of the ticket and virtually every
Democrat on that stage has said openly
and is a problem to have a socialist at
the top of the ticket people who judge
who is wildly dishonest he said it'll be
hard to defend socialism and he said
it's gonna be hard to defend socialism
he said this over the weekend but he
wouldn't raise his hand on that stage
would he do you believe that the
Democrats can defeat Donald Trump if
they have to defend socialism I think
it'll be a lot harder but the bigger
concern that I have is further dividing
the country you know when the campaign
says that either you're for a revolution
or you must be for the status quo most
of us don't see where we fit in that
picture he so he's ripping on the Bernie
Sanders socialism - but none of them
have the stones to actually just say to
Bernie you know this is a bunch of crap
and what you're promoting here is a
bunch of garbage and so instead they've
all been hijacked and there's and
they're supposed to be grateful for the
hijacking right they're supposed to be
grateful to Bernie and it's the Oscars
crowd trying to bop along - to Janelle
Monae that's all this is that's all this
is and it's hilarious
it is indeed hilarious now they've all
opened up their guns on each other and
that too is hilarious we're gonna get to
the the drama of Joe Biden who is just
falling apart but also smacking people
who to judge and properly so we'll get
to that in just one second okay guys
this is basically the last chance for
you not to screw up Valentine's Day like
what are you going to get for your
significant other if you're smart what
you're gonna get is jewelry right that
would be the smart thing to do you know
go big or go home
on Valentine's Day jewelry is when the
most popular gifts you can get for
Valentine's Day and there's nothing more
classic and timeless than fine pearl
jewelry
it doesn't need to break your budget at
the pearl source you get the highest
quality pearl jewelry and up to 70% off
retail prices why because the pearl
source cuts out the middleman by
eliminating markups traditionally five
times the original price and selling it
directly to you the Pearl source is just
fantastic I know the people who run it I
know the family that runs it they're
really honest and their jewelry is
beautiful I have jewelry from from the
pearl source for my wife has a necklace
she has earrings just gorgeous gorgeous
stuff at the pearl source you'll find
the largest selection of pearls
available anywhere
and each jewelry piece is custom-made
for you customize your jewelry based on
pearl size quality gold type length and
many more choices if you need it quickly
for Valentine's Day no problem the Pearl
source offers free two-day shipping on
every single order everything comes
beautifully packaged in an elegant
jewelry box ready to be presented as
soon as it arrives and if you're not
sure she'll love to gift no worries the
Pearl source comes with a no hassle 60
day money-back guarantee so it's
risk-free makes me happy because half
the time I pick the wrong jewelry for my
wife go to the pearl source save up to
70% off real to help retail prices and
for a limited time listeners to my show
can take 14 percent off your entire
order for Valentine's Day and this is
gorgeous gorgeous stuff go to the Pearl
source comm /ban enter promo code been
at checkout for 14 percent off your
entire order I've known the people
around the Pearl source for literally
decades at this point if you want fine
pearl jewelry at the best prices online
go straight to the source the Pearl
source that's the Pearl source calm /
been enter promo code been a check out
that's the Pearl source.com / been enter
promo code been in check out to get 14
percent off your entire order Karen gets
you more of the democratic circular
firing squad because it really is a mess
out there and we will talk about who is
picking up the momentum why Michael
Bloomberg is sleeping a little bit
better at night these days first if you
haven't noticed already 2020 crazy news
filled year and the election race is
just getting started
we know you need to know everything from
debate and primary updates to the latest
nonsense from the Democratic candidates
the best way to stay informed is to
become a daily wire member and get
comprehensive news and opinion from us
on demand so we are giving you 20% off
all new memberships that's 20% off all
new memberships when you use promo code
DW 2020 members get our articles had
free access to all of our live
broadcasts and show library the full
three hours of the Ben Shapiro show
selected bonus content access to the
mailbag and now my election insight
op-eds plus our new o accessed here gets
you into live online QA discussions with
me Andrew Clavin Matt Walsh Michael
Knowles plus our sites writers and
special guests let us answer your
questions and help you stay one step
ahead of the left if you haven't already
download the daily wire app so you can
get push notifications for breaking news
and special coverage it really is an
awesome feature again that is promo code
DW 2020 for 20% off join today stay
informed on all things 2020
again that's promo code DW 2020 for 20%
off join today stay informed on all
things 2020 we're the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
you
so as you may notice the circular firing
squad has now opened but not to the
extent that anybody's actually gonna
call out Bernie Sanders on stage for
being a socialist instead it is Joe
Biden going after Bernie Sanders and
people who to judge and you got people
to judge going after Bernie Sanders and
Joe Biden and Amy Klobuchar are standing
off to the side and going why not me I'm
the only person here who's won in a
purple state what the hell guys that's
pretty much how things are going the big
story of course is the collapse of Joe
Biden who was it be wired to wire a
front-runner in your democratic race but
is now beginning to fall apart and he is
getting desperate
now the reason he's falling apart is
because unfortunately for Joe Biden Joe
Biden is Joe Biden the big headline out
of the weekend was Joe Biden calling a
skeptical voter a lying dog faced pony
soldier which is one hell of a dis I
mean spitting spitting hot fire like
Eminem up there on that on that Oscars
stage
apparently he's dropped this line before
apparently it's a quote from a John
Wayne movie but this is the problem for
Joe Biden is every frame of reference he
has is from 1962 so here is Joe Biden
dropping a very very odd line at a woman
in New Hampshire I was a democratic
caucus there Mendo caucus no you haven't
you're a lying dog face pony-soldiers
you said you were but yeah now you gotta
be honest I'm gonna be honest with you
it was a little bit confusing in Iowa
the lion Dogface pony soldier Joe Biden
straight from 1962 also he left his
brain there because he's just saying
weird things all the time he said he's
losing track of time in the middle of
the speech he does this in debates also
he'll be like I guess I guess I'm out of
time and then I'll just kind of slow
randomly to a stop here he was yesterday
saying he was losing track of time again
all this is a really good look for a guy
who's approaching 1 million years old
you don't even talk about we don't even
we don't have a discussion about it
we're as introduced and I guess it was a
four five six days ago I can't remember
now I'm losing track of time my woman
named Chrissy and I was in Concord
what's he talking about
and why and whom also he doesn't know
what kind of shotgun he owns apparently
he was a 20-gauge but no a 12-gauge but
no a 10-gauge no an Inca just keeps
decreasing until he owns a negative four
gauge shotgun here is Joe Biden
explaining his a his gun ownership there
is a Second Amendment and you do have a
right to bear arms but
not unlimited right no amendment is
absolute I own a 20-gauge shotgun I own
a 12-gauge shotgun I'll answer questions
a minute sir
I own a 20 gauge in the 10 gauge shotgun
I just Skeets you don't even hunt well
ok again he's just he's so out of it at
this point and is it any wonder I mean
Bernie has energy communism comes with
the life-altering ability to suck energy
from everyone else so he's just been
living off everybody else's energy
apparently but the one thing that Biden
is is saying correctly is that people
judge is not a viable candidate for the
Democratic nomination which is pretty
much correct I mean people who judge
conventional wisdom says he has very
little ground support outside of the
early states New Hampshire and Iowa are
disproportionately white this is where
people to judge is likely to have most
of his momentum once you get down south
people to judge is in real trouble Biden
says budda judge has no support in the
black community and this of course is
true by polling data very Pete likes to
say the only time Democrats were in the
presidency as we nominate someone new
but here's what he never mentions the
only Democrats to win the presidency is
where we have overwhelming support from
the african-american community and don't
take it for granted and that of course
is also true and then he put out an ad
slamming mayor Pete he says listen while
I was vice president of the United
States this dude was having trouble
cleaning dog poop off sidewalks in South
Bend Indiana here is the ad that Biden
cut pretty brutal
both Vice President Biden and former
mayor Pete have helped shape our economy
Joe Biden helped save the auto industry
which revitalized the economy
in the Midwest and led the passage and
implementation of the Recovery Act
saving our economy from a depression
repeat Buddha judge revitalized the
sidewalks of downtown South Bend by
laying out decorative brick that's
pretty brutal and pretty true I Biden
himself went after mayor PD said what
have you ever done exactly like why are
you here exactly a judge a risk well
because people judge has been nothing
more and he's a good guy I like him and
he's a smart guy but he's been the mayor
of a city smaller than the city we're in
now and so what has he done what is who
has he pulled together does he know any
of the foreign leaders has he been able
to I mean Barack Obama was a different
story Barack Obama came from a large
state he was a United States Senator he
had run before he'd been involved in
international he had a clear vision of
what he thought the world should look
like and so on so but it's a very
different situation okay there are
actually a couple of real distinctions
between Barack Obama as a candidate and
people to judge people who judges more
like John Edwards a little bit than he
is like Barack Obama in the sense that
John Edwards was also a I believe first
term senator when he was nominated vice
president by John Kerry and then he'd
run for vice president when he ran again
in 2008 P Budaj is the mayor of a small
town in Indiana
he's never won more than I believe eight
thousand votes in his mayoral election
and when he ran statewide against
Richard Murdoch he got skunked like 72
percent against twenty eight percent or
something Amy Klobuchar said the same
thing she says listen we can't nominate
Budi judge I mean what are we messing
around here like why are we why are we
even talking about this this is crazy I
just think we can't mess around here and
we need a leader that brings a reciept
someone that has one in the reddest of
red areas not just talked about it and I
have done that consistently and when I
think about New Hampshire I think about
the fact that in 2016 Hillary only won
by two thousand votes and you see these
other states as you know like
Pennsylvania and Michigan and Wisconsin
this is of course is correct as well
now bootie judge for his part is
fighting back against Biden he's saying
yeah sure I'm no I'm no Barack Obama but
neither is Joe Biden which again is a
fair critique I mean Joe Biden was his
vice president and people who judge is
the mayor of a town that is smaller than
my neighborhood but still
it's a he's not wrong that Biden ain't
Obama he says and this is his quote he's
no Barack Obama well he's right I'm not
and neither is he neither is any of us
and this isn't 2008 this is 2020 this is
about how we're going to turn the page
and deliver a better future in the
country okay that that is a lackluster
answer at best years the problem for
Budi judge budgets very smooth he's got
no record he can't defend his lack of
record and also people to judge is I
think people are gonna get the general
impression that he is dishonest because
people try to portray him as though he
is a moderate and he's not actually a
moderate right again people who to judge
was defending late term abortion again
over the weekend I mean this is the most
radical position in the Democratic Party
platform he was sitting with NER all
pro-choice America which is the which is
the the wild anti-life organization and
here is people to judge explaining again
why he's in favor of late term abortion
being available usually we're talking
about cases where by definition if it's
late term a parent a family a woman is
expecting to carry a pregnancy to term
and then gets devastating medical news
something about the life or health of
the monitor or the fetus that creates an
unthinkable decision and in those
situations what we know is that decision
will not be made any better medically or
morally because it is being dictated by
some government official is the answer
heaps on giving and he's basically just
allowing late term abortion to go
forward which is the most radical
position in American politics on all
this by the way well he claims he's anti
socialism he's also ripping into Bernie
for being too rich so again he's trying
to have it both ways
Bernie for his part did slam booty judge
he says listen this guy keeps claiming
that he is some sort of man of the
people he's doing wine cave fundraisers
in in among billionaires here's Bernie
slamming bootie judge again Bernie's
more authentic than Buddha judges for
sure I do not believe that any group our
revolution or anybody else should be
raising money from wealthy people and
I'm not asking for their health they
legally can do what they want to do
because you have a corrupt political
system but I will also point out that
I'm running against a
candidate Pete Buddha judge among others
who has raised contributions from more
than 40 billion billionaires including
the CEOs of some of the largest drug
companies in America okay what are you
saying right there is true Buddha judges
responses yeah well Bernie has a lake
house which okay except that you're
supposed to be the man of principle when
it comes to these sorts of issues right
Buddha judges happened to take that
money because that's where he's getting
the money right he doesn't have a
movement like Bernie he doesn't have any
support outside of basically
college-educated white people right that
is the center of people who judge a
support base middle-class people
lower-class people in terms of income
they are not people to judge fans here
is Pete Buddha judge hitting Sanders for
being too rich but this isn't gonna play
Bernie's pretty rich and I would happily
accept a contribution from him look this
is about making sure we bring everybody
into the fight at a moment when we're
gonna be going up against Donald Trump
who with his allies are raising I think
the other day they raised 25 million
bucks
in one day this is a fight of our lives
I'm not a fan of the current campaign
finance system but I'm also the
insistent that we've got to go into this
with all of the support we can get
he is so wildly dishonest and here is
the problem for the Democrats so here's
what the race is coming down to at this
point Biden is fading really really
horribly there's a good shot that he
finishes fifth in New Hampshire which is
disastrous for him unless he has
expended every iota of cash he hasn't
have a de unless humans in Nevada he is
toast and if he loses Nevada and if
Bernie wins Nevada if Bernie wins Iowa
New Hampshire and Nevada
Bernie's the nominee if Bernie wins Iowa
New Hampshire and he finishes second to
Biden in Nevada then he still has a
decent shot at the nomination because
again all of these delegates are
proportionately split across the states
meanwhile one of these quote-unquote
moderates is trying to rise up and take
the Joe Biden mantle if that's pea
Buddha judge you really think that
people do judge is going to out-earn
Bernie Sanders with black voters in
South Carolina that's not a thing that's
going to happen Bernie Sanders has been
exposed to those orders for a very long
time but people who judge is widely
perceived as an upper class white person
and the fact that he is not rich is
mainly a function of the fact that he
left McKinsey and decided to go into
politics we all know that the minute the
people who judge leaves politics he will
be extraordinarily wealthy again
the chance of the people who judge is
going to be worth not a lot of money at
age 60
our zero people to judge will be worth a
fortune and everybody knows that okay so
the Peabody jej replacement of Joe Biden
at the top of the sort of moderate wing
of the Democratic Party is uncomfortable
at best the best replacement for Joe
Biden at the top of that Democratic
Party sort of moderate wing would be Amy
Klobuchar but Klobuchar camp can't buy
attention which is wild again because I
think that Kopitar is the most electable
of these Democrats if you were gonna
take any of these Democrats and put them
up against Trump
Chloe char would be the one a cobra
chart does not off put people should win
suburban women running away she is more
moderate on a lot of the key issues than
these other Democrats are she does it
she openly speaks out against socialism
like she'd be very difficult for Donald
Trump to beat in a lot of these swing
states Amy Klobuchar she's the person
who would be most dangerous to Trump
probably in a national election a
bloomberg here's the problem here's what
happened it's so weird in this race
early on the question was going to be
there really a couple of different lanes
in the in the Democratic Party and we
had suggested maybe three lanes there
was the intersectional lane that was
gonna be filled by Kamala Harris and
Cory Booker and that Lane started to
fall apart pretty quickly because nobody
from the intersection of Lane could buy
a ticket in the other two lanes the
other two lanes were the so-called
moderate wing of the Democratic Party
that was club achar and Biden and Biden
was dominating that wing and he was
shutting people out and then there is
this third wing and third wing with
Sanders and Warren so the grand
assumption is that somebody from that
middle wing of the Democratic Party was
going to reach out to the intersectional
wing or reach out to the socialist wing
and that a crossover candidate from that
middle wing was going to have the best
shot at winning the Democratic Party
nomination instead as it turns out
because Biden had really closed the door
to so many people in that middle wing
because he had been this very weak
frontrunner but he'd been prohibiting
anybody from rising as he collapsed it
turns out that people rushed into that
middle wing and the only person who is
left in that far left wing is Bernie as
soon as Elizabeth Warren imploded then
Bernie became the only person left
standing in the wing the domination of
that wing meant he only had to reach
over a little bit into the
intersectional wing or the moderate wing
and pick up just enough votes to win the
nomination so right now Bernie Sanders
is indeed the front-runner in this race
and that's bad news for him because
guess what every bad thing he ever said
is gonna come up in this election and
he's gonna get asked about it and his
answers are insufficient so he was asked
by Jake Tapper about his past comments
on things like wage caps and Bernie
Sanders gets mad about this because he
has
never been willing to answer questions
about all the dumb things that he has
said in the past there's Bernie Sanders
early in your political career way back
in 1974 you said that it should be
illegal to earn more money than someone
could spend in his or her lifetime you
proposed a maximum wage cap on the high
needs test what it was that it was 45
years ago you know look Jay can all due
respect yeah seven years before I was a
lot did you go back to my third grade
essay when I was in PS 197 about 30 or
50 yeah that was 50 years ago let's talk
about my mayor's record where I was a
transformative mayor reelected three
times you know we could go back to
things that I said in the seventies I
don't think it's productive but it is
productive and the reason it's
productive is because he has never
disassociated from anything he said back
in the 70s I also love the conflict a
Bernie Sanders thing let's talk about my
mayor records my mayor's record back in
the 70s but nothing I said back in the
70s bottom line right now is that no one
appears able to stop Bernie Sanders no
one appears able to stop Bernie Sanders
because no one has the stones to stand
up to Bernie Sanders in the same way
that nobody has the stones at the Oscars
to just say the best picture should win
and Best Director should win and Best
Actress should win and the best actor
should win and we should all stop with
this sort of woked scolding it's really
irritating and stupid nobody has the
stones to stand up to Bernie and say
what you are saying is crazy known as
the state has the stones to actually go
full James Carville and say you guys are
way off the rails here way off the rails
and so Bernie is likely to be the
nominee and the media by the way is
completely panicked about this because
they're beginning to realize just what a
disaster this is Rahm Emanuel who's
Obama's chief of staff he says listen
Donald Trump would crush any of these
people right after it right after the
debate he looks around goes um the we
are screwed we're in serious trouble
there were flashes of strength flashes
where people had some concern of wobbly
moments and answering questions
no you have to basically close your eyes
see them on a stage with Trump and say
who really looked like they were gonna
go mano-a-mano toe to toe because he's a
vicious debater we saw what he did with
Hillary and so that's my concern as a
Democrat is we're not there yet we got
we have a ways to go
hey this is correct this is correct
everybody's starting to panic inside the
Democratic Party and they should okay
time for a quick thing that I like and
then a quick thing that I hate so things
that I like so I talked about how my
wife and I are watching cheesy 1990s
action looks the peek cheesy 1990s
action flick is of course Conair the
reason this is piqued is because it is
Jerry Bruckheimer just blowing things up
basically every five minutes there's an
explosion for no reason for some reason
the world is just filled with
unbelievably flammable material it is
also full Nicolas Cage with like the the
southern accents in the long hair and
everything John Malkovich is great cuz
John Malkovich is great in anything and
he's and he's terrific on screen and and
Steve Buscemi shows up to be real weird
it's it's it's pretty fantastic here's a
little bit of the trailer for Kanye if
you're looking for a dumb action movie
tonight the issue here
three tons of people affair
eight years it's so great Caroline but
he's got like the long hair like a 1970s
rocker this summer check your weapons so
spectacular this movie it is your seat
it's so bad and so good at the same time
in the movie yep oh yeah you know about
this movie is understand that the movie
opens with Nicolas Cage who is a former
basically Special Forces Navy SEAL guy
he comes home and he's seeing his wife
for the first time in years right or at
least in months he goes to a bar
he wants a chance there and three drunk
truckers decide to confront him and rip
the medals off of his shoulder for no
reason at all
he then gets in a fight with that right
they attack him with a knife and he
kills one of them and then he is
sentenced to ten years in prison for
this why because the judge says in the
dialogue the judge literally says in the
dialogue that the rules do not apply in
the same way two people who are in the
military because their hands are like
deadly weapons okay which by the way is
a lawyer that's not a real thing that
like at all but it's it spectacularly
dumb movie pretty fun to watch you can
check out Kanye okay other things that I
like so a assi demonstrating why she has
an econ degree from Boston University
she was speaking over the weekend
economics and she somehow came up with
an economist named Milton Keynes which
is some weird say here here is a OC
talking about the well-known economist
Milton Keynes which is which is like
this okay so like the well-known
economist Frederick Marx here here she
is I was just reading today about how
Milton Keynes a famous economist back in
the day predicted that by 2030 US GDP
would grow six to eight times what it is
which would allow for every day people
to work 15 hours a week something about
that is that Keynes as predictions
weren't completely wrong so fresh so
face incredible freshness and faceless
Milton Keynes solid stuff there that
wasn't the best part of her little
Instagram fest over the weekend she also
had on her boyfriend Riley Roberts to
discuss how white people can combat
racism which is just and everything that
is wrong with the democratic party on
the Oscars in in one little clip here I
think one of the like effective ways is
just to talk
and kind of help teach them about why
some of the things they believe or say
or think are wrong
not necessarily racist but that they're
wrong and that'll sort of like ship away
and you know contribute to some
development in this area but not
necessarily take somebody from like
being a racist and not being a racist
sometimes it's just always being open to
learning about racist things that we may
have said or done without judgment and
defensive Ness and later he's like oh
god I'm gonna get lectured aren't I
I answered that question wrong in a is
he's gonna lecture me about my
internalized racism isn't she
you're just gonna be so awkward it's
gonna be so awkward I'm gonna have to
sit there like Tom Hanks well aoc wraps
at me it's gonna be weird she can put on
like a weird flowery coat thing and
she's gonna yell at me about how I'm not
woke enough it's got to be it's got to
be strange being on the left really and
being lectured about your own woke 'no
swell you're not woke enough but you are
your woke or than the right I mean at
least you're not a right winger but
you're not woke enough and just spend
all day thinking about your own racial
sins spectacular stuff okay I think
we've run out of time for things that I
hate plus there were a lot of things
that I hate today anyway so we'll be
back here later today with two
additional hours of contents otherwise
we will see you here tomorrow as we
approach the New Hampshire primaries
Bernie Sanders in the lead people to
judge quick on his heels and Joe Biden
way the hell back we'll talk about all
of that very soon so stick around we'll
see you here a little bit later I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling assistant director Pavel white
house key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SCI events audio
is mixed by Mike rapport amina hair and
makeup is by Anika Geneva the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 25 Oscar winners
quote Karl Marx president Trump
tortoises critics and the Democratic
presidential candidates B clown
themselves in Friday night's debate we
will examine the politics of show
business the show biz of politics and
why the left can't mean check it out on
the Michael Nolt show